the intention the goal of this work is
to free the user of the cage of screen
mouse and keyboard the screens are
getting larger and larger some people
have two screens but it's still pretty
much the same way of working with with
your data with your applications
you just have windows side by side and
you switch between windows between
applications which is always kind of a
mental switch also a mental context
switch and so we thought of how would it
be - if the whole table would be just a
digital workspace where you can work
with your familiar applications like
you'd normally do with paper spreading
paper on your desk for reading for
writing for doing whatever and just do
that with your computer programs and
that's a prototype of that we can just
use virtually any application like
Google Earth and the screens are very
high resolution and they are capable of
of touch and multi-touch and so I can
use my Google Earth in in a familiar way
but just if it was a piece of paper on
my table so I can use a web browser and
just work with the web browser in the
same way whatever application you are
used to you can use with this system but
on a desk and free just from being
aligned to the screen boundaries you
just spread everything onto the table as
you like it and let's prefer it and
that's a much more natural way to work
with a computer but without forcing
people to learn a completely new
paradigm of working because the
program's themselves can be still just
those the users are familiar with you so
we just adding something to the familiar
way of working with the computer
widening up the space widening up the
possibilities of interaction you can use
touch or we also have the familiar
vertical screen in that setup that
might be there or might not depending on
the particular use case well whether
it's an engineering workplace or an
accounting workplace or a digital
content creation workplace so this is
very flexible you might want to use the
mouse so then we just use the mouse from
the normal way of working so this is not
pretty standard but so if we decide to
go with that continue working here then
that's completely seamless if you really
want to type quite quickly and want to
have the haptics of a of a physical
keyboard then you just use it so we have
one here you just place it where you
won't want to use it that's also just a
matter of preference and we support as
much different input methods as possible
it's running on Linux the main component
is where you normally have a genome or
the unity desktop for instance that's
replaced by our own software component
so essentially it replaces the window
manager by a-1 which can do arbitrary
things with 2d and 3d so freely
transformable windows transform in terms
of scale and in rotation and whatever
you want to do with it and in addition
it's also capable of compositing 3d and
2d content so we did another prototype
which is the conference table where
people sitting around the table and
because you are not limited to any
particular orientation of your
applications because you just rotate and
put every content to the person who is
interested in you create a canvas for
collaboration without the limitation of
only being able to use particular
content or work with particular
applications that remains completely
free this is the larger scale of this
continuous display space we can also
enhance this or extend this display and
interaction space to large display
environments like this tile display wall
which is just made up from off-the-shelf
HD televisions and just do the same
thing as on the table and just spread
our information our windows or content
across the whole wall so think of a
future of
where you have a table like our moody
touch table and then somebody comes in
it gives a means of a very seamless way
of working between individual work and
collaborative work and environment
supporting using your documents
everywhere where some display space is
available how big are those screens and
therefore what sort of resolution we're
talking about each screen has a full HD
resolution so 1920 by 1080 4 by 4 tiles
it's a KS Wow okay so can we watch some
films yes yes of course that's also nice
there's also a nice environment to watch
films it requires a bit more work on the
software infrastructure because it's
running on the cluster this one just to
be able to drive the displays with
sufficient performance so how many
computer running that limit or so each
equipped with two graphics cards or one
graphics cards has to drive two displays
only so that
yeah just sufficient GPU power is
available for each display you need also
very fast interconnects so we are
investigating different different high
speed interconnects from InfiniBand to
10 Gigabit Ethernet does that foster is
just off the shelf Network is it oh yes
currently it's just off the shelf
network and that's what we are currently
developing towards to bring that to have
high speed interconnect and also to be
able to to distribute arbitrary content
across different nodes in the cluster
and all the GPUs along that
but just this one only that will fall
over that one times tango 18-7
so you don't need to do anything
particularly complicated to multiply
these two together